[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUISE GRAY: Thank you for
taking up your lunch hour this.
So I wanted to start with how
many people in the audience
are vegetarian?
A couple.
Is anyone in the audience vegan?
AUDIENCE: I'm almost
a vegan-arian.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, yeah,
I did that as well.
I found it really tough.
Anyway, OK, great.
And who thinks they ought
to be vegan or vegetarian,
but you can't resist
when they have something
nice in the restaurant
or occasionally if you
go to your granny
for Sunday roast,
you sort of are slightly
British about it?
Is anyone?
Yeah.
So that was me.
I was working as an environment
correspondent on the "Daily
Telegraph" newspaper.
So I was interviewing climate
change scientists all the time
and writing about
climate change.
And I knew that
emissions from livestock
make up more than all the
transport in the world put
together.
And I knew that one of the
easiest things I could do
was to give up eating meat.
I also knew all
the other threats.
I don't know if any of you
have seen "Cowspiracy,"
but obviously, growing an
animal takes more water.
You might clear forests.
There's all the fossil
fuels and growing
the feed for the animal.
And at the far end
of the scale, you
can talk about it driving
species extinctions, ocean
dead zones.
And again, I thought, well,
the easiest thing I could do
was go vegetarian.
But I'm a farmer's daughter.
And I go home, and I
try to be a vegetarian.
And my granny or
my dad would say,
well, this is venison
from the hill, you know?
These animals are
eating all the trees.
What's wrong with eating this?
Or it's free-range cattle.
You can see them out
in the field there.
They don't look miserable to me.
So I thought, OK, I am going
to do something quite extreme.
I'm going to only eat
animals I kill myself.
So I'm getting a
little ahead of myself.
These are all the other
benefits of agriculture.
I thought obviously I could
see, from my own family--
farming families who make their
money out of raising meat.
But they also sustain the
countryside when you think
about drystone walls and what
you see when you go on holidays
to the countryside--
carbon storage,
past delays are actually just as
good as storing carbon as rain
forests--
waste-- if animals are being
killed, why not eat them?
So I decided to be an
ethical carnivore, which
is, to me, to only eat animals
I killed myself, because then I
thought I can truly justify it.
So I started quite slowly,
because honestly, it
was a bit of a scary idea.
And I went oyster shucking.
I don't know how many
of you eat oysters.
But they grow all around
the British coast.
And they're actually quite
a sustainable meat to eat,
because when oysters feed,
they're filtering the water.
And a lot of the oysters
around the British coast
are an invasive species.
So we want to get
rid of them anyway.
So that was quite an easy start.
In fact, I guess quite a few
of you been to California.
And there are people there who
call themselves ostrovegans.
So they only eat
mussels and oysters,
because they think that
they don't feel pain,
because they don't have
the nerve endings for it.
And by farming them,
you're actually
improving the environment.
So it's the one meat
that they'll eat--
only in California, I think.
And then there was
fishing as well.
And fishing was where
I really started
to think about my connection
to the environment,
because you have to
stand on a river bank
or go out to sea
for a long time.
And it really
forces you to think
about what's happening in
the environment around you.
You have to choose a fly.
You have to be very quiet.
You have to understand
what the fish are feeding
at on in that time of year.
So it started me thinking
about my connection
as a sort of hunter gatherer.
But of course, I also
had to be realistic,
because that's not how I'm
supposed to get our fish.
We get it from the seas.
And there's a wonderful book
called "The End of the Line,"
which I read.
And I went out on
a fishing boat.
And it's quite a brutal
industry, fishing.
The animals usually
die in the hold.
And it's also having a real
impact on the environment.
I'm sure many of you know
the statistics from dredging.
So I tried to think about
are there sustainable
ways to eat fish?
And one of the biggest
things I found,
having gone to fish markets,
is we only five species,
which is ridiculous, and
lots of those species
are actually under threat.
Cod off our own coast are
still not a healthy population,
because we so overfished them.
So why not try--
I'm sure Ben knows all
the different species,
but coley and different species.
So that was an ethical
way I felt around fishing.
Another option is farmed
fish, which takes the pressure
off wild fish.
So I went to a salmon farm,
and salmon farming really
caused a lot of
damage in the past.
Sea life live on the salmon.
And that passes to
the wild population.
And they said wild fish from
other places around the world--
may see anchovies
from places like Peru.
And that has an impact on
ocean ecosystems there.
It is something I
think is improving.
And when I went to
visit those places,
I genuinely found people
in the West Islands
of Scotland, who said that
it was providing employment
in really remote areas.
But they could do so much
to improve how it's done
and close circulation.
So the sewage from the fish
have been going into the oceans.
And I'd urge you to look
at it with wild fish--
Marine Stewardship.
Council.
But then now there's an
Aquaculture Stewardship
Council.
So hopefully, if we put
pressure on the organizations,
we can get sustainable
farm fish as well.
But it's not
straightforward-- nothing is.
So that was all quite easy.
But I had to move onto
other animals to eat.
And the first thing
I shot was a rabbit.
And that was quite
upsetting, because you
have to take responsibility.
And I never really
got over that,
but that was a lot
of the motivation
in writing the book in
that when you eat animals,
an animal dies.
And taking that on
really upset me.
I cried.
The gamekeeper I was with cried.
And that's really
where the book begins.
But the big question is,
why did I carry on doing it?
But I looked at the people
like the gamekeeper I was with,
who go out and shoot
animals to eat themselves.
And they had a much
greater understanding
of the countryside than many
conservationists I knew.
And I wanted to learn
from them, and I
wanted to continue the journey.
So I did.
And I got a little
bit better at it.
So I learned to
shoot with a rifle
and to do it as cleanly and
quickly as I possibly could.
I ate squirrel, which is
a good example of where--
they're being controlled
anyway to help
the red squirrel
population come back.
So I fed my girlfriends
squirrel satay,
and they enjoyed it very much.
And shotgun shooting is
the other type of shooting.
It's different from
using a rifle--
very challenging.
I did shoot a pheasant.
Obviously, in Britain, that
has different implications,
because it's very mixed up
with landownership and class.
People only traditionally
do it who have the money
and live in the countryside.
And it kind of exposed me.
But I wanted to go
into that, because I
think it's really interesting.
And two-thirds of our
farmland is managed
for game birds in this country.
So what effect is that
having on the countryside?
And my argument is there
are good and bad shoots.
So let's talk about
it openly rather
than saying they're all bad.
And I like to eat
pheasant I'm afraid.
But the best way to eat
pheasant is roadkill.
And there's lots
of them on the road
at certain times of the year.
So I also learned how to
identify roadkill safely,
which is--
people often ask me about
the legal implications,
and you have to
take responsibility
for yourselves, people.
But you can do it.
And the ultimate thing I killed
was a stag with my father.
And that was quite
an emotional journey,
because my dad
hunted all his life.
It was something my brother
has done, but I've never done.
And I had come to a realization
of why I was doing it,
because I had to question was
I doing this to impress my dad.
But by the time I
got to that stage,
I was doing it for
myself, because only
you can take responsibility.
You have to be in control of
yourself and what you're doing.
And that was an
amazing experience.
It really taught me
a lot and gave me
great respect for the animal.
And it took me quite
a long time to eat it
with all my friends and family.
I tended to share
all the meat I ate.
But all this is
very nice talking
about going out and hunting
and fishing and something
that requires a lot
of time and energy.
You could argue
it's something you
need to be quite
privileged, but you
can do it-- anyone can do it
if you put the time and energy
into it.
But most of us are eating
meat that's obviously farmed.
And I wanted to look
at that as well,
because that's where most
of the environmental impact
is of course.
And in Britain, we eat 1
billion farm animals a year.
So I wanted to find
out how they're raised.
Chickens was a good start,
because in this country, that's
what we're eating the most of.
Compared to the '50s where
you might have it once a week,
we're now eating chicken
three times a week
and 2.2 million chickens a day.
But have you ever seen any
chickens in the countryside?
Where are these
chickens being raised?
So I went to a chicken
farm and saw them indoors.
They usually are raised,
tens of thousands, in a barn.
And they are gassed
when they slaughtered.
And the big realization
with chickens
is they're being raised on
such a scale it's too dense.
The animals can't
move around easily.
They've been so bred to
have big breasts that they
collapse on their legs.
But there are very
small things you can do.
I looked at RSPCA
Assured chickens.
And they're still
indoors, but at least they
have daylight and
room to roam around.
So there are things that
you can do quite easily.
That's me in a chicken farm.
I also looked at pigs.
I went to Denmark, which is
where we get most of our pork
from in this country.
And again, it was
very intensive,
and I found pigs more
difficult, because I
would argue that
chickens indoors
can be quite happy, but pigs--
when you see pigs
outdoors, they just
love to root in the ground,
and I like to see that,
and that's for my pork
to come from that.
But in Denmark, they do
it on a massive scale,
and they have a slaughter
house with glass walls where
you can see it happening,
which is quite interesting.
I would argue that it doesn't
tell you the whole story.
But it's quite an
interesting insight
into how other cultures
are more open about where
their meat comes from.
And I went into
abbatoirs, of course,
because that was a big
question I was trying to ask--
where does our meat come from?
And, again, I found it
very upsetting initially.
But I wanted to continue
to try and understand,
because the people who
were doing it I felt
deserved my respect.
I think if you are
going to eat meat,
you should respect the people
that do it on your behalf
or not eat meat at all.
And I also went and
visited a lot of farmers.
And these people weren't
earning a lot of money
and raising really
good meat, you know?
This is a man
called Roley Pusey,
and he's raising sheep
on National Trust land.
And it's on the
Sussex Downlands.
And there are flowers
and birds that
survive in that farmland
as it's managed.
And a consequence of
that is the sheep.
So why not eat them and
keep that cycle going?
So that's the other reason
I continued to do it,
because I respected
those farmers
and wanted to understand their
business, not dismiss them.
And I did some home slaughter as
well, which was pretty intense.
And I learned about butchery.
I was following everything
all the way through.
So again, having said all that,
people's first question is,
well, that's all
very well, but how
do I judge where
my meat comes from?
And there are labels
you can look out for.
I'm always quite cautious,
because labels can change.
And I think you
can't rely on that.
It's probably something
that Google talk about a lot
is you can't rely
on a corporation
to make your decisions for you.
It's about your
education, which is
what I'm trying to
do through my book is
to give you all the information
so you can make the best
decisions.
But there's definitely
a few that I've already
mentioned MSC fish, but
RSPCA Assured, which
is just a little
bit more expensive,
but ensures better welfare,
and of course, organic.
And there's a new one
called Pasture Fed, which
means they've been kept
outdoors and only fed
on pasture, which is a new one.
And it's pretty good.
Or just eat less.
Or don't be evil.
I was thinking of
the Google tag line,
because I kind of think
if you are concerned
about the environment,
eating less meat is
just one of the easiest
things you can do.
And a lot of the charities
have written reports on that.
And I think they
keep it quite quiet,
because they don't want to seem
like they're lecturing people.
But it is a fact.
It really helps reduce
your carbon footprint.
And also, it's good
for your health.
Too much red meat
is bad for you.
And I actually ate much less
meat than the average person.
People think the
ethical carnivore
must be eating most meat.
But actually, compared
to most people,
I ate a lot less
meat doing it myself.
And I tried out all
the alternatives,
including insects.
I'll pass them
around in a minute.
But there are other
in-vitro meats
where they're growing meat from
stem cells, which freaks me out
personally.
It's a bit weird.
But lots of vegans
welcome it and say they
would eat burgers from
meat grown in a test tube--
and plant protein,
which is something
that's huge in Silicon Valley--
well, Google, I know,
are looking into it,
but also I think
some from Twitter--
Impossible Foods-- Beyond Meat.
And they're all trying to find
plant-based alternatives, which
I think is likely
to be the future.
So I do think that we will be
eating less meat in the future.
And I think the
ethical carnivore
is about the
philosophical side of it
that people don't often consider
that eating animals obviously
has an impact.
The animals are raised
and killed on our behalf.
So I hope it gives people
a better understanding
of that side of it.
And I'll pass on some insects,
and we'll do some questions.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
So I've got a few
questions initially.
LOUISE GRAY: Yes.
I'll sit here.
SPEAKER: There's
more awareness now
around how animals are
kept, as you touched on,
and the environmental
impact of eating meat.
So as a result, people are
turning to a vegan diet.
What do you think
the implications
would be if the whole
population went vegan?
Do you think it's a sustainable
way of life for humans
and for the environment?
LOUISE GRAY: Well, there
have been studies done,
I looked into that.
And there was one done--
it was published in the
"National Proceedings
of Science" last year.
And it found that
it would reduce--
if everyone went vegan, it would
reduce carbon emissions by half
compared to--
compared to 2005 by 2050.
But I personally don't
think that's realistic.
And it's certainly not
in the short term anyway.
And there's been
other studies that
found that if just a third--
if people ate less
meat, then it would have
a similar impact over time.
And if you think about it, if
you asked everyone to go vegan,
I think you'd have quite a small
percentage of the population.
But if asked people
to eat less meat,
I think you're talking the
majority of the population
in the future.
And that could have
a much bigger impact.
And I do think you'd
lose a lot, because a lot
of our agriculture is
based on animal inputs,
and you think about pigs,
they give the waste.
We feed them waste.
And we have lots of
cultural associations
with the meat, which I wouldn't
necessarily want to lose.
So I think less
meat is a better one
than just everyone going vegan.
SPEAKER: You have the
Sunday roast, for example.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Of all the meat
substitutes available,
and those in the
pipeline, again,
that you touched on,
which ones do you think
will be the most popular,
and the ones most adopted
by the population, and then
the most sustainable as well?
LOUISE GRAY: I think
plant proteins,
because a lot of our
lifestyles now-- we
demand a lot of processed meat.
But I think people are really
uncomfortable with cheap meat.
And that's processed
meat, and I think
that alternatives like
Beyond Meat chicken strips
and things like that
are really growing.
And I that's the thing
that will really take off
in the future, because the
technology is improving
to make it taste better.
And in terms of
sustainability, people often
argue that's still soy
protein and stuff like that.
But those companies--
I think the people who
are buying those
things are demanding
that it comes from a
sustainable source.
And it's still more sustainable
than feeding the soy
to animals.
So I think that we'll see a
great growth in that area.
SPEAKER: What do you see people
eating in five years' time?
What do you think
the challenges are
going to be around
re-education the public
so they change
their eating habits?
LOUISE GRAY: Eating
Less and better meat,
because I am not the only
one talking about it--
like Jamie Oliver, Hugh
Fearnly-Whittingstall-- really
powerful celebrity chefs.
I think the big challenge is
time, because people don't--
I can talk about, hey, why
don't you go to a butcher
and try a new cut of
meat or try offal?
But that's a lot of work
for people with busy lives.
So I think it's about
putting the time and possibly
the money towards those
better cuts of meat.
And that is important, because
the farmers that I talked about
in my talk are relying
on people to carry
on buying that red meat.
And that's reducing as
well as processed meat.
And I don't think we should--
sometimes it's a
statistics about you people
eating less meat--
it's because they're just eating
less from butchers and stuff.
And I think if people are
going to eat meat, that's
the kind of stuff
they should get
is from farmers and butchers.
And the other
challenge is gender.
As you can see from
the audience here,
women are quite interested
in it, and men aren't.
And I was talking about-- in
the book I dismiss that and say,
hey, it doesn't mean
you're less macho.
And I thought about
it, and I thought
if you go to a
barbecue in London
and a guy comes along
with veggie burgers,
no one would raise an eyebrow.
But a lot of places in
Britain they would be pasted.
So I think that that
needs questioning,
because that's a
little bit ridiculous,
because a lot of guys love meat,
and it makes them feel good.
But it doesn't make
them more macho.
That's ridiculous.
So we probably need
to challenge that.
And the other thing,
in five-years time,
I think we maybe see
a little bit of a--
just I was thinking
about how things go.
You generally go in cycles,
and clean eating and veganism
is so popular now.
But I feel like it'll
maybe settle down
into incorporating some of
those habits into how we eat
rather than saying people
should go vegan and eat clean,
because I don't think that
works for a lot of people.
But I think a lot of
messages from that movement
will come into
everyday eating more.
So it would be easier
to eat less meat
and still have a good diet.
SPEAKER: Great.
Thank you so much.
LOUISE GRAY: Not at all.
SPEAKER: Does anyone
have any other questions?
Wonderful.
AUDIENCE: I have three.
LOUISE GRAY: OK, cool.
SPEAKER: Want to take the stool?
AUDIENCE: Of course
I'll take the stool.
LOUISE GRAY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello, friends,
how are you today?
Thank you for coming to Google.
LOUISE GRAY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: It's
lovely having you.
What was the weirdest
thing you ate
to your standards of weirdness?
LOUISE GRAY: Oh, OK, loads
of really weird things.
So the squirrel was quite
weird and the insects.
But I caught a fresh cod and I
ate the egg sacs, which is roe,
and it was amazing.
It was the best
thing I've eaten,
because it's like caviar.
That is quite weird
to have fresh cod roe.
And I ate the stag
hot in a stew, which
was really delicious,
and the liver,
and the kidneys,
which aren't so nice.
And that was-- yeah,
that was [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned the stag.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah
AUDIENCE: And you say
you went with your dad.
Who actually killed the stag?
You or your dad?
LOUISE GRAY: Me.
Of course.
AUDIENCE: I'm
sorry to be creepy.
How did you kill the stag?
LOUISE GRAY: With a rifle.
Yeah, but read the book
for the full details.
AUDIENCE: It's fine.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, but
cleanly with a powerful rifle.
AUDIENCE: Where in
London do you think
is a place that we can
find the fish that are
outside of those five species?
Because actually, I'm not--
LOUISE GRAY:
Billingsgate Market.
AUDIENCE: But in Billingsgate
Market will they educate me?
LOUISE GRAY: At 5 o'
clock in the morning.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm not like--
I go in-- show me a fish.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah,
AUDIENCE: They'll show
me the most expensive
LOUISE GRAY: You'll have to be
up at 5 o'clock in the morning.
But if you go down
to Billingsgate,
you will see tens of species of
fish, and you'll just be like--
I had no idea these existed.
And it doesn't smell
of fish either,
because it's all so fresh--
well, not too badly--
less than you think it would be.
And it's mind blowing.
You don't know what a
haddock or a cod looks like.
Well, I didn't until I
went to a fish market,
and then you see hake,
and ling, and monkfish,
and like on that picture,
the ugliest, strangest fish.
So it's quite amazing and quite
joyful to see the variety.
And then there are restaurants
which do cook those fish.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LOUISE GRAY: I can't I
can't think of one, sorry.
I don't live in London.
AUDIENCE: You're a novelist.
That's fine.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And last but not
least, if one is too hard,
you can give me three.
What are you three or your
favorite food in the world?
LOUISE GRAY: Raspberries.
AUDIENCE: I like that answer.
LOUISE GRAY: But you want meat?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
It's your favorite food.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, raspberries.
AUDIENCE: Raspberries?
So you die tomorrow, and you
want a bowl of raspberries?
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
There's some in the
entrance, by the way.
LOUISE GRAY: Good.
Good.
My nephews and nieces
always ask me that question.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
just curious how
are you continuing with it now.
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, lots of
people ask that question.
I said at the end of the
book I'm stopping it now
and largely because
I want people
to be able to pick up
a book in 10 years time
and it still be
genuine, you know?
So I wanted to do something
that was sustainable for me.
So I definitely eat
less meat than when
I started the whole
project, because I
question it a lot more.
But now, actually, the further
I go, that does recede,
and you do think about it less,
which is interesting itself,
because that's how--
I think you have to be honest--
that's how humans think,
you know?
You can watch a video
and be really concerned
about something.
And then six months later
when you're eating a burger,
you don't really think about it.
And I do that as well.
So it's receding.
But I eat less meat.
And I am continuing to learn
about shooting, and fishing,
and doing it myself,
because I never
wanted to do it as a one off.
I wanted to learn
those skills, and that
takes longer than 18 months.
So I'm still doing that, but
not a huge amount, because it
takes a lot of money and time.
And I'm also trying to explore
things like different fish
species and different cuts of
meat, because I'm quite greedy,
and I really enjoy that.
So yeah, so I'm what I call--
I'm trying to be an
ethical carnivore.
What I call an
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering what your farming
family thought of the book?
Have they read it?
LOUISE GRAY: They love it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have they changed
their eating habits?
Or are they still--
LOUISE GRAY: It's
really interesting.
Sometimes it makes
me kind of cringe
when people are like,
don't worry, Louise,
it's not like processed
chicken or something.
And it kind of makes
me cringe, because I
find it difficult to tell
other people what to eat.
Even though the book
is about what you eat,
I'm just telling my story,
because otherwise, you
feel great--
you feel a bit didactic
and finger wagging.
But really positive--
I thought they
might feel like I was attacking
them, because a lot of them
raise meat.
But they were actually really
open minded and welcomed it,
because a lot of meat in
Britain is really high quality.
And it would help farmers
to talk about the quality
and why it should be
appreciated and paid more,
because in this
country, we struggle
to compete with processed
meat from abroad anyway.
So yeah, they loved it,
which was very nice.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
you said, I won't eat this--
I will not kill x?
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah.
Lots of people ask, hey, did
you eat a badger, or a fox,
or something weird like that?
And I was like, no,
why would I do that?
Or I didn't do the
squirrel was unusual.
But it was quite tasty,
and it was accessible.
But I wasn't going to
push exotic or weird meats
for the sake of it.
And I really am not
interested in that,
and I'm not really
interested in--
like if I travel
to other countries
where there are meats,
which in our country
we'd find weird
like dog or horse.
I really don't--
I feel like I understand
cultural taboos,
and I feel them.
And that's fine.
I don't need to cross them.
So yeah, I have no interest
in doing that much.
AUDIENCE: Firstly, I think
when the news came out
you were coming to see
us, I was so excited.
I said to a couple people,
I was like, oh, my god.
But this really
resonates with me,
because I went
vegetarian two years ago.
And this was the
principle that I usually
take as well, which is I believe
that obviously people just eat
meat.
They just get it in
a cellophane packet.
They don't even tie it
back to an animal diet.
So I wanted to
actually follow that,
which is I will only eat
meat that I'll kill myself.
But I love animals
so much, I will
cry at a cartoon animal dying.
But obviously, I haven't
used meat, because I simply
can't kill an animal.
How do you see the
most effective way
of getting the message
across to the masses?
Have you successfully
transferred
or changed any of
your friends' mindsets
without maybe overstepping
boundaries of scaring
the hell out of them?
LOUISE GRAY: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sat them down and made
them watch slaughter videos.
And I have lost some
friends over that.
And I realize that's the
wrong way of doing it.
So yeah, how would you think
is the most effective way
to spread the message?
LOUISE GRAY: It is interesting--
the reaction to this book.
I thought I'd get a lot
of pushback from vegans--
people would be upset by it--
but actually, not that much.
And I've actually had sometimes
more aggressive people
who really love meat,
and do not want to know,
and want me to shut up.
So it's surprising
who you can annoy.
I think it has to
be really gradual.
If can talk about nudge
theory and make it positive.
So if you say to people
you can't eat stuff,
then they shut down.
And if you say you have
to vegetarian or vegan,
then I think they
just shut down.
But I think if you tell
them like, oh, my god,
have you tried this
amazing new food that
happens to be a plant protein?
Or have you ever tried offal?
Or have you tried
meeting your butcher?
So I think through a series of
positive messages rather than--
AUDIENCE: Scare tactics.
LOUISE GRAY: Scare tactics.
But so much of what you said was
interesting, because I'd say--
a lot of people say you
should only eat animals
if you've killed them yourself.
But I would argue
lots of people--
that would be too much.
Like you, and that's unrealistic
and ridiculous anyway.
And I felt like, I'm
not sure I'd necessarily
wanted to do that.
But I just felt
role as a writer.
And I had an opportunity
to explore a subject
so people didn't have to.
SPEAKER: Does anyone
have anymore questions?
Wonderful.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
LOUISE GRAY: Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]